lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
pensemos en cómo los tipos de cambio
pueden afectar el comercio incluso
podemos pensar un poco en cómo podrían
afectarse entre sí aunque
profundizaremos en eso en futuros vídeos
imaginemos una situación en la que el
joan chino yuan chino se deprecia frente
al dólar estadounidense y para
visualizar esto que estamos diciendo
déjenme dibujar la oferta y la demanda
del mercado de divisas para el yuan
chino entonces nuestro eje horizontal
será la cantidad de yoanis y luego
nuestro eje vertical será el precio del
yuan en términos del dólar
estadounidense dólares por johann hemos
visto esto antes
esta es la curva de la oferta del yuan
sería la gente que posee joanes pero tal
vez desea cambiarlos por dólares y luego
esta es la curva de la demanda del yuan
es la gente que tiene dólares y que está
interesada en cambiarlos por johannes y
aquí habrá un tipo de cambio de
equilibrio
llamémosle
1 y aquí la cantidad de equilibrio en un
período de tiempo q sub 1 y para que
todo esto esté claro esta es nuestra
curva de oferta para el yuan o su 1 y
esta es nuestra curva de demanda para el
yuan de sub
1 entonces una situación donde el ión
chino se deprecia frente al dólar
estadounidense puede suceder de dos
maneras una es que la demanda del yuan
se mueva hacia la izquierda o podría
suceder que la curva de oferta del yuan
se mueva hacia la derecha que la demanda
se mueva hacia la izquierda podría
significar que por alguna razón la gente
que posee dólares está menos interesada
en obtener yuanes y que la oferta se
mueva hacia la derecha podría significar
que la gente que posee joanes esté de
repente más interesada en obtener
dólares hagamos esta última digamos que
la oferta se mueve hacia la derecha sólo
es para mostrar un escenario en el que
el yuan chino se deprecia frente al
dólar estadounidense entonces podemos
ver muy bien
la mente en este mundo que si nuestra
demanda no se mueve obtenemos este tipo
de cambio de equilibrio y sub 22 y
también hay una cantidad de equilibrio
diferente pero podemos ver que el yuan
chino se depreció frente al dólar eso
uno es probablemente 15 centavos de
dólar por jon chino y probablemente el
psuv 2 es 10 centavos de dólar por
johann chino pero ahora que entendemos
la depreciación que podemos visualizar
lo que estamos diciendo cuál sería el
impacto en el comercio y lo voy a pensar
de dos maneras qué va a pasar en china
primero en china vamos a pensar en los
consumidores chinos los consumidores
chinos poseen yuanes y probablemente
quieren comprar bienes estadounidenses y
qué pasaría con el costo de esos bienes
estadounidenses bueno supongamos que los
proveedores estadounidenses ofrecen sus
productos en un precio fijo en dólares
digamos que eres general motors una
compañía estadounidense de automóviles y
que hay un automóvil fabricado en eeuu
que cuesta
mil dólares bueno en un mundo en el que
el yuan chino se depreció frente al
dólar el monto de yuanes que corresponde
a veinte mil dólares ahora se ha
incrementado ahora necesitamos más
yuanes por dólar porque estamos en un
mundo en el que hay menos dólares
porción entonces los bienes
estadounidenses son más caros en china
bienes estadounidenses son más caros en
china que va a ocasionar esto en el
comportamiento en este ejemplo de
automóviles cómo van a decidir las
personas comercial entre eeuu y china
bueno si los bienes estadounidenses en
este caso automóviles se vuelven
relativamente más caros van a querer
comprar menos automóviles
estadounidenses y si hablamos de todos
los productos estadounidenses que
importa china van a disminuir porque son
relativamente más caros y qué va a pasar
en eeuu en eeuu bueno supongamos que los
productores chinos ofrecen sus bienes a
un precio fijo del yuan
ahora necesitamos menos dólares por
johann de modo que los bienes chinos
ahora son menos caros para los
compradores estadounidenses los bienes
chinos son menos caros en eeuu porque
con cada dólar podemos comprar más
yuanes suponiendo que los bienes tienen
un precio fijo en yuanes así que
podríamos decir que las importaciones de
eeuu que vienen de china van a aumentar
las importaciones de eeuu que vienen de
china van a aumentar y es interesante
que tal vez tengamos un círculo negativo
de retroalimentación porque que podría
pasar si las importaciones de china que
vienen de eeuu disminuyen bueno eso
significará que menos personas chinas
van a estar interesadas en convertir sus
yuanes en dólares para comprar bienes
porque no están comprando tantos bienes
estadounidenses y eso puede provocar que
la curva de oferta se mueva hacia la
izquierda del mismo modo en un mundo en
el que las importaciones de eeuu que
vienen de china
incrementan bueno pues ahora de repente
habrá más personas estadounidenses que
estén interesadas en convertir sus
dólares en yuanes y eso tal vez mueva la
curva de demanda a la derecha entonces
tal vez cualquiera de estas situaciones
podría tener el efecto de ayudar al yuan
chino a apreciarse un poco ahora en
vídeos anteriores hemos hablado sobre
muchos factores que podrían mover la
curva de la oferta o la curva de la
demanda hacia la derecha o hacia la
izquierda pero sería interesante pensar
en cuáles serían los efectos de los
cambios de la tasa de interés en cada
país y ahora podríamos ligarlo no sólo a
lo que ocurre con las curvas de oferta y
demanda sino que podemos pensar en cómo
afecta el comercio pensemos en una
situación en la que el gobierno de eeuu
incrementa su endeudamiento el gobierno
de eeuu incrementa su endeudamiento
hemos hablado sobre esto en vídeos
anteriores eso probablemente producirá
un aumento en las tasas de interés
porque tenemos un gran prestatario
aquí incluso podríamos tener un efecto
desplazamiento debido al incremento de
las tasas de interés menos privados van
a pedir prestado en los eeuu entonces
esto incrementaría no siempre pero esto
produciría un incremento en las tasas de
interés en los eeuu ahora sí tenemos un
incremento en las tasas de interés en
los eeuu qué pasará con las personas en
china bueno ellos tal vez dirían hoy
estamos más interesados en tener dólares
porque podríamos obtener un interés
mayor en una cuenta bancaria en dólares
y esto podría tener el efecto que vimos
antes donde dijimos que los poseedores
de yuanes están interesados en
convertirlos en dólares estadounidenses
de modo que la curva de oferta del yuan
se mueve a la derecha lo que tendría el
impacto de la depreciación del yen chino
que es con lo que empezamos este vídeo
entonces podríamos ver algo como que el
endeudamiento del gobierno de eeuu que
aumenta las tasas de interés
realidad podría tener un impacto en el
comercio de hecho podría ser que los
productos estadounidenses sean menos
competitivos en china y los productos
chinos más competitivos en los eeuu y
acabo de hacer un escenario en el que la
curva de oferta se desplaza hacia la
derecha pero también se podría imaginar
una situación en la que los préstamos
del gobierno que aumentan la tasa de
interés en los eeuu podrían incluso
cambiar la curva de demanda recuerden la
curva de demanda estará determinada por
el sentimiento de los poseedores de
dólares y cuánto quieren convertir al
yuan pero si las tasas de interés en los
eeuu aumentan ahora podrían decir oye si
podría querer ahorrar en los eeuu en
lugar de invertir en china o convertir
mi dinero a yuanes o ahorrar en cuentas
bancarias chinas entonces aquí lo vamos
a dejar lo más importante para apreciar
aquí es que los tipos de cambio y el
comercio están muy vinculados y que
cosas como los préstamos del gobierno
pueden
las tasas de interés lo que puede
afectar los tipos de cambio lo que puede
afectar el comercio hasta el próximo
vídeo